bonsoir bienvenue dans le 78 société
alors dans ce nouveau de débat de
société on va s'intéresser ce soir au
travail le dimanche et vraiment le sujet
du moment il y a eu ces magasins de
bricolage à qui l'on a dit vous fermerez
le dimanche sous peine d'Amand
d'ailleurs il brave l'interdit il y a
aussi ce collectif les bricoleurs du
dimanche qui eux demandent à travailler
ce jour-là et puis il y a trois invités
en plateau ce soir pour en débattre
Pierre-Henri bovis bonsoir vous êtes des
jeunes de la droite sociale le courant
de Laurent vquier et vous vous êtes pour
vous allez vous expliquer ça en quelques
instants Pascal Gret bonsoir vous êtes
avocate en droit social responsable du
parti chrétien démocrate pour le Centre
et Sud divine et vous vous êtes contre
je suis contre voilà et à côté de vous
Clément Ortega ptier conseiller régional
Front de Gauche PCF et vous êtes
également contre on verra comment le PCD
de Christine Boutin et le Front de
Gauche se rassemble sur cette même idée
alors le travail le dimanche est-ce que
c'est une bonne chose est-ce que c'est
une évolution est-ce que c'est une
contrainte c'est la question à laquelle
on va tenter de répondre mais d'abord je
voudrais qu'on jette un petit coup d'œil
euh vers le code du travail et sur les
exceptions françaises qui sont
extrêmement nombreuxes je me tourne vers
vous parce qu'elle gûterit parce que
vous êtes avocate en droit social alors
il y a d'abord cette premier article de
loi qui dit dans l'intérêt des salariés
le repos hebdomadaire est donné le
dimanche ça c'est le premier premier
article alors on pourrait dire que c'est
le préambule en quelque sorte de la loi
nous sommes particulièrement attachés
puisque c'est jean-f poisson qui est
député parti Démocr du du Parti
Chrétien-Démocrate qui a déposé un
amendement pour qu'effectivement la loi
soit chapautée par par ce grand principe
général alors ça c'est la loi ensuite il
y a les exceptions et alors là ça
devient un véritable casse-etête parce
que dans les exceptions il y a
l'ameublement les fleuristes les
jardiniers les transports les
établissements de soins les entreprises
de spectacles les restaurants est-ce que
vous savez le nombre d'exceptions qu'il
y a au travail de dimanche écoutez je
pense qu'on arrive à un nombre
considérable puisque si on devait les
les les numérotés effectivement on
arriverait à un chiffre considérable
mais en plus ce qui est très inquiétant
quand on lit la loi on voit que ce sont
des termes généraux c'est-à-dire que à
partir du moment où on est dans une
situation où la le non travail du
dimanche serait un préjudice pour le
public ou encore mettrait à mal le
fonctionnement de l'entreprise et bien
l'ouverture peut être demandée et
justifié un véritable cassette et JEC ce
troisème c-etête donc le le code du
travail qui dit le repos c'est le
dimanche il a les exceptions qui sont
nombreuses on vient de le voir et puis
il y a les fameux puces les périmètres
d'usage de consommation exceptionnel qui
sont donc délimités par le préfet avec
une dérogation pour une durée de 5 ans
je rappelle juste que dans les isines il
a notamment au clés sous-bois Orgeval ou
encore à Vellis ville à coublet bon bref
on s'y retrouve plus moi je trouve que
c'est beaucoup est-ce que c'est une
spécialité française d'avoir cet hour
Guo il y a un flou est-ce que vous êtes
tous les trois d'accords sur le fait
qu'il y a un véritable flou et que c'est
très compliqué de s'y retrouver je pense
que je pense que si déjà tous les trois
on narrive pas à se mettre d'accord sur
le fait que c'est un flou bon je pense
qu' on sera d'accord sur rien B vous êes
d'accord c'est un flou c'est un flou
mais un flou dangereux pour la personne
humaine pour le salarié parce que ce à
cause de ce flou et bien on peut euh
finalement quasiment institutionnaliser
le travail du dimanche dès aujourd'hui
ouais pierrean et Beaufils vous vous
êtes pour le travail le dimanche
qu'est-ce que vous respondez à Pascal
Garay qui dit il faut pas généraliser le
travail le dimanche bah Pascal gatray
nous nous dit tout simplement que en fin
de compte on est en face d'un millefeu
réglementaire c'est-à-dire que il y a
des magasins qui peuvent ouvrir le
dimanche d'autres pas aujourd'hui la loi
qu'est-ce qu'elle dit elle dit que vous
pouvez si vous vendez des parfums dans
un aéroport vous pouvez ouvrir le
dimanche si vous vendez des parfums dans
une gare vous ne pouvez pas ouvrir le
dimanche à Paris si vous avez un magasin
au Champs-Élysées boulevard
Saint-Germain ou dans le quartier du
Marais vous pouvez r le dimanche
maintenant si vous avez un magasin
boulevard Osman près de l'Opéra comme on
sait qu'il n'y a personne près de
l'Opéra le dimanche vous ne pouvez pas
ouvrir le dimanche la loi aujourd'hui
elle dit ça c'est d'une égalité
exemplaire alors elle dit ça donc ça
veut dire en gros il faudrait revoir la
loi je pense que Clément or vous êtes
d'accord là-dessus je pense qu'il faut
vraiment revoir la loi parce que ce flou
il est dû entre autres à des pressions
et entre autres du patronat pour revenir
sur la règle qui était l'article la
première des règles et le patronat a
fait tellement pression sur un certain
nombre de secteurs que à chaque fois ça
vaut des heures et des heures de
négociation et sur lesquelles on lâche
tel métier mais pas tel autre et puis
finalement on finit quand même par tous
les lâcher donc oui il y a un flou mais
parce que c'est dû à une pression sans
cesse sur le travail du dimanche alors
il y a un flou on est bien d'accord tous
les vous êtes d'accord par contre là
vous êtes pas d'accord c'est qu'est-ce
que doit dire la réglementation vous
vous dites il faut
autoriser ouverture le dimanche mais
pour tout en fait moi en fait surtout ce
que je dis c'est que c'est pas forcément
un problème ou en tout cas une i ça une
problématique sociale ou ou politique
c'est vraiment législatif aujourd'hui la
loi elle dit ça face réglementaire il
faut réglementer il faut revoir la loi
maillet de 2009 à laquelle on a ajouté
des dérogations à tout va on s retrouve
plus comme comme vous l'avez dit tout
tout simplement euh aujourd'hui on a une
politique qui nous targue tous les jours
qu'il faut créer de l'emploi qu'il faut
relancer la
croissance qu'il faut lutter contre le
chômage et à côté de ça François
Hollande et l'ensemble de la gauche
puisqueil faut pas prendre à part le PS
hein nous dit tout simplement que enfin
en tout cas refuse d'entendre les
salariés qui eux veulent travailler le
dimanche qui veulent essayer de
travailler plus pour gagner plus on peut
pas en même temps tenir un dialogue sans
forcément agir à côté qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça alors
c'est vrai il y a les salariés et on l'a
entendu il y a les salariés qui
demandent à travailler le dimancheous on
est d'accord extrêmement importante de
cette discussion nous savons qu'il y a
des salariés qui ont perdu au lendemain
d'une décision de justice la possibilité
de voir le salaire d'un jour doublé il
ils sont perdants mais ils sont perdants
pas seulement à cause de cette décision
justice ils le sont bien en amont parce
que si s'ils en sont arrivés à sacrifier
leur dimanche et bien c'est parce que
la leur salaire hebdomadaire n'est pas
suffisant donc si il faut réfléchir à
quelle société on veut demain quelle
société on veut demain est-ce qu'on veut
une société oou l'homme et est
finalement réduit à quelqu'un qui
produit qui consomme et qui meurt est-ce
qu'il doit être un consommateur 24 heur
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 est-ce que c'est ça
qu'on veut je pense que c'est pas comme
ça qu'on envie vous
savez je voudrais juste dire écoutez
souvenez-vous du film de Colin Serou qui
nous dit et nos enfants nous accuseront
je vous assure que si on continue dans
cette voielà à faire à faire de l'être
humain un simple consommateur on le
réduit complètement il a d'ut dim sa
très bien que si un saill travaille le
dimanche il peut très bien négocier un
jour chaôé avec son employur ou la
commen
faut à chaque fois maintenant de prendre
le salarié qui a le bras tordu qui est
obligé d'aller travailler
dimanche je suis avocat je veux dire
comment comment je défends le dossier le
dossier de cette personne à qui on a
demandé de travailler le dimanche et qui
refuse discrimination comment est-ce
qu'elle le prouve est-ce qu'il faut
qu'elle aille chercher qui peut
témoigner pour elle est-ce que c'est
celui qui a été embauché à sa place
voyez c'est un dossier extrêmement
compliqué qui demande une énergie folle
et qui en plus on n'arrivera pas à
rapporter la preuve parce que si faut
aller chercher le témoignage de celui
qui a été embauché à votre place je vous
souhaite bien du courage autre chose fa
produ les salariés qui se manifestent
devant les mé qui signent des pétitions
moi j'en ai vu j'en ai vu peu qui se
plaignaient justement de travailler le
dimanche par contrainte ENF en tout cas
moi je les ai pas entendu je sais pas si
les téléspectateurs les ont entendu mais
en tout cas personnellement non moi j'ai
plus entendu des milliers de justement
de salariés qui eux qui eux mais non
mais qui eux justement souhaitaent
travailler le dimanche qui eux
trouvaient ça scandaleux qu'à côté de ça
François Hollande disent tous les jours
qu'il faut lancer la croissance qu'il
faut créer de l'empo d'cord ça on peut
en parler de la création de l' par le
travail du
dimanche alors juste pour reprendre un
mot parce que vous dites effectivement
le est-ce que le travail de dimanche va
créer de l'emploi je voudrais juste
citer c'était un article publié
aujourd'hui même dans les échos du
président de la Fédération nationale des
dirigeants commerciaux des dirigeants
commerciaux de France donc je pense
c'est un monsieur sérieux et qui dit bah
oui pour lui le travail le dimanche
pourrait créer entre 10000 et 100000
emplois ou vrai pas vrai bienû mais bien
sûr que
non mais il y a quand même une une
question il va falloir qu'un économiste
m'explique comment les les ménages avec
un un avec des revenus qui ne cessent de
diminuer peuvent consommer plus tout
d'un coup parce qu'on va ouvrir les
magasins de dimanche que ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui il va falloir va falloir
mexliquer attendez attendez le pouvoir
d'achat n'a pas augmenté il est en train
de s'effondrer faut m'expliquer comment
tout d'un coup par magie on arrive à
augmenter la croissance surtout que un
des chiffres que le monsieur
manifestement n'a pas précisé c'est que
l'ensemble des magasins qui ont ouvert
le dimanche ces 10 dernières années ont
fait le constat que leur chiffre
d'affaires n'augmentait pas mais que
c'était une répartition entre le samedi
et le
dimanche je vais vous répondre vous
parlez
d'économie est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire combien touch les syndicats en
attaquant les magasins qui ouvrent les
dimanches juste un chiffre 35 millions
alors maintenant qu'on vienent pas me
dire que c'est pour défendre le salarié
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose vous parlez d'économie vous parlez
vous parlezcom les magasins devoir payer
ne vont pas au syicat paréconom sais pas
aujourd'hui qui peutès je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui qui peut me dire en totale
objectivité couvrir le dimanche freine
la croissance freine l'emploi freine
l'attractivité touristique je ne sais
pas qui aujourd'hui un peu de
sensééraé
tour
ouais ah ben excusez-moi mais c'est on
rappelle juste à qui on a demandé de
pas idologique décide quand même de
rester ouvert et de payer une amende une
amende de 120000 € par jour ouvert en
totale illégalité oui là il va falloir
et c'est ainsi aussi ce que risqu les
magasins de bricolage qui ont été
condamnés à fermer évid briolage
aujourd'hui on dit très bien à briama
non non mais toias pas droit d'ouvrir le
dimanche laisse plutôt ouvrir Castorama
ou lur Merlin bah comment voulezvous
dire un magasin non toi tu fermes et tu
laisses l'autre faire du business c'est
pas possible un moment donné il faut
être un peu cohérent c'est a il y a
quand même une réalité incohérente de
certains magasins qui sont obligés de
fermer comme rorama et d'autres qui sont
obligés d'ou N a fait le sketch pendant
des semaines et des semaines
surun côté on peut ouvrir le dimanche et
l'autre pas oui sauf que quand
effectivement Nicolas Sarkozi allit voir
les caissières en disant mais est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on ouvre le dimanche caè
disait oui la question que n'a pas posé
Nicolas Sarkozi c'est combien vous
gagnez tous les mois exactement parce
que c'est ça la question c'est que
aujourd'hui vu le niveau des salaires je
peux comprendre que des milliers de gens
demandent à travailler le
dimanche ça veut dire que on nous parle
du coup du travail on ne parle pas de la
valeur travail c'està-dire que le
salaire que touchent aujourd'hui les
salariés en France n'est pas calculé à
sa juste valeur bon ben au moins nous
sommes nous serons d'accord donc pour
dire une très mauvaise chose donc ça MOS
nousutre
chose on parle de grands groupes qui se
font des milliards d'euros soit par la
spéculation soit parce que il font des
pressions je veux dire une entreprise
qui est capable de dire je vais payer
120000 € tous les dimanches et que je ne
vais même pas le voir dans mes ligne
alors moi ce que je propose à ces mêmes
entreprises c'est vous restez fermé le
dimanche et vous augmentez vos salariés
vous
mais d'ailleurs pi Bice vous avez des
des des garanties de ce travail de
dimanche vous souhaitez aussi que les
salaires soient bien sûr alors nous ch
quand même qu'on vous pose une question
il faut qu'on vous comment voulez-vous à
partir comment voulez-vous que le
travail du dimanche soit créateur de
richesse si le pouvoir d'achat puisque
le pouvoir d'achat ne va pas augmenter
comment voulez-vous que si le pouvoir
d'achat est bloqué comment voulez-vous
que le travail le dimanche soit créateur
de richesse c'est quelque chose mais on
ne va pas acheter ce qu'on achète le
samedi pardon ce qu'on achète le samedi
on va pas aller l'acheter le diman di
sauf à ce que par un coup de baguette
magique le pouvoir d'achat est augmenté
entre la salari qui tout la semaine
et qui rentrent chez eu à 22h ils ont
peut-être pas forcément envie ou en tout
cas le temps d'aller faire les magasins
VO touche bien du doigt la question du
choix de société et dans quel monde nous
voulons travailler et donc il n'est pas
normal il n'est pas normal dans une
société moderne où on tout est tout
passe par les ordinateurs et où on peut
être aidé par la révolution
informationnelle se dire mais tiens on
va travailler de 8h à 22h et on va en
plus de cela travailler le weekend non
c'est c'est c'est humainement le
développement humain ne peut pas le to
parce du coup vous avez vous
avez vous avez plutôt une position
économique et vous avez plutôt une
position philosophique moment moment moi
je suis bien d'cord moi je suis bien
d'accord moi je suis bien d'accord qu'on
puisse rester en tout cas tenir un
discours de gauche mais après l'économie
reprend le excusez je sais pas si c'est
un vrai discours de gauche mais là parce
que en l'occurrence Pascal G on peut pas
on peut pas dire qu'elle soit une
personne de gauche c'est partiétien
ce serait vraiment très sectire de dire
qu'on est tous à droite sur ça et tous à
ga
sur bien sûr mais donc c'est sur un
sujet on peut très bien avoir des
sensibilit je je vais vous répondre tout
à l'heure nous ce qu'on propose c'est la
libéralisation totale du travail
c'est-à-dire qu'on propose au salariés
de faire le choix de faire le choix de
travailler le dimanche mais bien sûr que
si un salarié peut très bien mais un
salarié peut très bien négocier avec son
employeur ou avec la convention
collective de secteur pour travailler ou
non le dimanche nous ce qu'on propose
donc pour le travail nocturne on en a
pas parlé mais je j'emplace juste un mot
on propose une augmentation
substantielle du salaire après 21h puis
que ça passe un travail de nuit de moins
50 % c'est ce qu'on propose en tout cas
la droite sociale et le dimanche une
augmentation substantielle de presque
100 %. voilà non alors écoutez vous
parlez de libéralisation de liberté
comment voulez-vous qu'il y ait liberté
quand justement le contrat de travail
est construit sur le lien de
subordination on ne peut pas ça ne peut
pas c'est quelque chose d'
logique liberté he mais après ça pas
dans un sujet un philosophique mais on
pe salarié et le choix réellement c'est
pas un choix réel c'est parce que le son
pouvoir d'achat n'est pas suffisant
qu'ilaccepte de sacrifier son dimanche
donc il ce qu'il faut c'est c'est
répartir
l bien sûr que si ça c'est un robinet
démagogie il y a un double discours on
Robin ENF c'est
simplement on nous dit un moment donné
on est dans la crise on doit faire des
sacrifices on paye plein plus d'impôts
au passage le gouvernement Hollande ne
se prive pas de matraquer fiscalement
les classes moyennes et d'ailleurs que
les classes moyennes tel un prince Jean
voilà au début il nous av le discours du
Robin des bois pour taxer les riches
maintenant c'est le prince Jean qui qui
va voler qui va voler les classes
moyennes et à côté de ça les
salar regardez
pas cé de Cé
de ouiors à côté de ça les salariés qui
eux veulent travailler plus pour gagner
plus on leur dit non non non arrêtez
vous travaillerez pas plus si vous
voulez travailler le dimanche bah tant
pis pour vous vous allez autre
partécoutez ce que je vous dis ce que
vous dis il faut lisser c'està-dire
cette augmentation de salaire qui est
lié au travail du dimanche parce que les
salariés ont sacrifié leur dimanche et
bien il faut qu' ça soit lissé sur le
travail sur la
rémunération et si on reprend l'exemple
de l'Allemagne vous savez que
l'Allemagne a une loi très
restricemag la lo est très laissez-moi
terminer la loi est très restrictif
quand on travaille dominical on peut pas
dire que ce soit un mauvais exemple à
l'Allemagne et il fer et il ferme et il
ferme 18 par de salaire en Allemagne
quand même les salaires en Allemagne
sont plus bas qu'en France ça faut sair
je propose une petite pause on on va
reprendre ce débat il est passionné
passionne je voudrais qu'on qu'on écoute
le le député socialiste Jean-Philippe my
il est député de la 11e circonscription
il est venu sur notre plateau il y a
quelques jours et pour lui je pense que
ça ça va vous vous plaire aussi par qu'
gos ce qu'il dit c'est aussi une
question de de philosophie pas question
donc pour lui de travailler le dimanche
on écoute jean-fip Mané par mon
engagement politique par mes convictions
philosophiques personnelles je suis
opposé au travail au travail du dimanche
à la généralisation du travail du
dimanche c'est-à-dire je ne souhaite pas
que l'on généralise
aux entreprises et au secteur public le
travail le dimanche vraiment je des gens
qui veulent travailler mais je tiens à
ce principe c'est ça la réalité
d'ailleurs on vit suivant ce principe
alors évidemment il y a des exceptions
chacun comprend bien qu' hôpital secteur
public doit travailler le dimanche
chacun comprend bien que les boulangers
travaillent le dimanche on ne généralise
pas le travail le dimanche je suis
totalement
opposé mais on met les exceptions je
dirais qu'on les met en cohérence on
réfléchit à ces exceptions qui existent
qui sont nombreuses en France on essaie
de de les rationaliser quoi hein
évidemment les gens ne comprennent pas
qu'on puisse aller acheter des meubles
le dimanche et pas acheter des outils
pour pour les monter d'autant que
souvent les magasins sont ces magasins
sont pratiquement sur le même créneau
quoi ils vendent en partie les mêmes
produits donc sont souvent voisins aussi
sur un plan tout à fait ça n'est pas
cohérent voilà donc j'appelle de mes
vœux cette mise en cohérence de de ces
exceptions voilà alors cette mise enohér
de ces exceptions elle va peut-être
avoir lieu puisque il y a une mission de
concertation qui a été confiée à
l'ancien président président de La Poste
Jean-Claude Bay doit remettre son
rapport fin novembre ah bah clé ptier
vous souriez quand on non mais quand on
voit les conditions de travail des
salariés de La Poste oui il y a de quoi
il y a de quoi s'attendre à un bon
rapport non là c'est une très bonne
chose en tout cas pour avec ce rapport
c'est que au moins on a l'honnêteté de
dire qu'aujourd'hui voilà cette loi
maillet plombée de dérogation et voilà
qu'il faut en tout cas remettre tout à
plat
qui m en péril l'équilibre de la société
parce que si vous n'avez plus de
respiration dominicale vous n'avez plus
de lien social donc vous allez
finalement réduire l'homme à être ben
finalement quel quelqu'un qui consomme
et qui produit point barre alors que
l'homme a d'autres dimensions il a des
dimensions émotionnelles des des
dimensions culturelles des dimensions
physiques il faut il faut faire
attention à ça comment comment est-ce
que vous allez produire de l'ocytocine
comment comment non mais écoutez alors
écoutez écoute c'est
quoii j'ai parlé de pH écoutez vous
savez bien vous savez bien que la
plupart la plupart des union sexuelle se
passe le weekend si l'un des deux du
couple travaille ça ne se passera plus
et alors qu'est-ce qu'on va faire domin
plombe les relations bien sûr mais c'est
évident mais c'est évident c'est évident
et y compris y compris l'Union mais si y
compris y compris l'Union con écoutez
vous allez vous allez expliquer ça donc
à ses salariés qui n'arrivent pas
forcément à finir la fin du mois non
mais attendez au moins comme ça vous
pourz faire je pense qu'une bonne fois
pour toutes il faudrait qu'une bonne
fois pour vous pass une bonne fois pour
toutes vous preniez en compte ce que je
vous dis cette majoration du dimanche
nous proposons de la lisser sur la
semaine est-ce que ça c'est audible pour
vous ça c'est juste ça le qu le départ
de façon parce que on veut construire on
veut construire une société autre si
nous construisons une société où nous ne
sommes je me répète mais que des que des
producteurs que des consommateurs et
bien oui nos enfants nous accuseront
vous comprenez ils n'auront plus le
temps d'avoir de liens social ils ne
pourront plus même faire la fête on aime
faire la fête pourra plus faire la fête
parce que le lendemain je travaille
c'est assez simple quand
même
c'est mais oui la dimension sociale le
bien vivre ensemble existe c'est une
vraie question de société la notion du
travail alors on peut balayer ça d'un
revers de main en disant que c'est
philosophique on peut dire que c'est
philosophique mais c'est ce qui régit
notre société et c'est bien notre lien
avec le travail oui enfin al au passage
parce que ce lien social on nous a auss
on nous a aussi sorti le même discours
pour les heures des fiscalisé quand même
je tiens à le souligner on nous a quand
même dit non non mais attendez on va pas
vous allez pas être payé pour si vous
faites des heures supplémentaires ça tue
le lien social on n a quand même sorti
ce même discours et aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement avoue qu'il
a fait une erreur et que donc il va
revenir sur cette défiscalisation
sûrment oui mais le travailler plus pour
gagner plus a été aussi une erreur donc
le travailler plus pour gagner plus a
été une erreur et personne ne l'a vu
personne ne l'a vu par contre
travailleer plus pour gagner
pareil ça c'est 80 % des salariés qui
l'ont vécuquer com AR on va arrêter un
débat où le patronat dit il faut
travailler plus par parce qu'il faut
relancer la machine économique ce n'est
pas comme ça qu'on relance une machine
économique c'est pas en pressant encore
plus les salariés et juste sur une
question par les salar quand même
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quand même le
gouvernement et en tout cas Bruxelles
avoue quand même que la France fait
partie des pays où on a le moins d'heur
de travail quand même enfin j'espère que
là on d'Ordou alors et alors mais et en
quoi c'est Mali c'est mal en quoi c'est
mal je sais pas il faut juste regarder
l'état du pays l'ét on est un des pays
où il y a le moins d'heur de travail
mais on est les salariés les plus ou
après fa voilà c'est ça il faut
peut-être prod productivité c'est on
travaille moins mais on travaille plus
on on on on produit plus c'est ça la
réalité et et ça pour le coup tous les
économistes pourraient le dire c'est
qu'effectivement si on se repose si on
organise correctement le travail
effectivement nous sommes de meilleurs
producteurs et moi j'aspire euh pas
uniquement le weekend à pouvoir avoir
des relations sexuelles mais qu'on
réorganise le travail pour qu'on puisse
avoir des relations sexuelles et du
plaisir tous les jours voilà ouais alors
on va faire à nouveau une pause on va
pas parler de relation sexuelles ni le
dimanche voilà on on va revenir sur le
travail ouais ouais société encore une
fois vous voyez c'est c'est pas
forcément une réflexion économique
l'économie elle doit être un outil pour
l'homme mais pas l'homme l'homme ne peut
pas parle de de question sociales moi je
voudais qu'on aille à la rencontre de
des 5 continois qu'on aille voir les
habitants et on leur a demandé ce qu'il
pensaient du travail le dimanche on va
écouter leur
réponse ça dépend les catégories
professionnelles dans qui sont concernés
par par ça quoi tout c'est je pense
qu'il y a les métiers où c'est pas
nécessaire de travailler le dimanche et
puis il y en a d'autres oui c'est voilà
c'est le je pense qu'on mélange la
notion de loisir et de et travail il y a
des gens qui doivent travailler le
dimanche par rapport à tout ce qui est
urgence et cetera mais voilà après ça le
reste c'est bien d'avoir aussi du jour
de repos personnellement
euh non ça ne me plairait pas de
travailler le
dimanche donc dans la mesure où on n pas
obligé bon maintenant faut reconnaître
que les magasins de bricolage tout ça
bon quand on travaille toute la semaine
c'est bien utile
de de pouvoir en profiter le weekend
quand on travaille pas bon je pense que
s'il y a des employés qui souhaitent
travailler le dimanche je vois pas
pourquoi on les empêcherait je pense que
ça fait partie de l'évolution
effectivement de la société oui ceux qui
veulent travailler doivent pouvoir
travailler voilà par contre c'est vrai
qu'il y a des contraintes au niveau des
entreprises au niveau des des salariés
aux-mêmes donc il faut prendre en compte
tous les aspects c'est sûr voilà moi je
trouve que ces micrrottoir résument bien
un peu la la pensée ce qu'on a dit
autour de par on par on parle
d'évolution de société de choix de vie
et cetera évidemment enfin à partir du
moment où on a un salarier parce que
vous dites que on peut ensuite le
weekend cheler à des bon des loisir et
cetera mais al qu'est-ce que vous faites
des célibataires qu'est-ce que vous
faites des gens seuls et cetera enfin
vous
voyez non mais
par on on va revenir quand même sur le
travail monsieur ce monsieur ce monsieur
tout fait c'était pas ça c'était pas ça
le fond du problème ce que les gens
disaient Dansou ce monsieur est tout à
fait raison dans le sens dans le sens où
il dit que si il y a des salariés qui
veulent travailler le dimanche il y a
des salariés en tout cas qui veut
essayer de voilà Deah de travailler de
gagner plus et cetera ils peuvent c'est
un choix c'est un choix qui est proposé
on nblige personne mais mais dans C
contir si vous l'avez entendu on parle
aussi de contrainte il faut pas que ce
soit fait sous la
contrainte
cont mais comment voulez-vous comment
voulez-vous ça fonctionne autrement mais
oui voilà ça fonctionne tout très bien
j'aimis bien j'aimais bien m'entendre
c'est moi ces salariés qui justement
aujourd'hui travaillent le dimanche et
qui disent oui on travaille sous la
contrainte parce que je les entends pas
évidment écoutez soyez un petit peu
réaliste ils vont évidemment
paszà vous d'ailleurs travailler le
dimanche mais bien sûr bien
sû s sous la contrainte ou c'était
volontaire moi j'ai travaillé le
dimanche sous la contrainte mais quand
on retire toute ma période politique
parce que c'est un engagement c'est
différent mais oui j'étais obligé de
travailler le dimanche pour pouvoir
financer mes études c'était dans
l'obligation de financer mes études
qu'and si on regarde parce que c'est une
vraie question souvent on nous dit les
les étudiants doivent travailler le
dimanche ils peuvent pas travailler à un
autre moment moi ce qui m'insupporte
c'est de dire que les étudiants qui font
partie de la richesse de du pays soit
obligé de se salarier pour pouvoir
travailler 75 % des échecs de première
année est dû à des problèmes de travail
c'est-à-dire que à un moment donné les
étudiants sont obligés de choisir entre
continuer ses études ou aller travailler
et cette situation-là on va la retrouver
en de pire en pire parce que la
situation sociale est en train de
s'aggraver donc ce n'est pas une bonne
évolution de la société elle creuse en
plus les inégalités sociales puisque
quand vous avez des parents qui peuvent
vous payer vos études bien vous n'avez
pas à travailler mais ceux qui sont
obligés de travailler pour pour payer
leurs études le logement on va prendre
par exemple c'est très bien le cas é
aprèspend mais après tout dépend des
parents moi par exemple je suis la
faculté j'ai la chance que mes parents
voilà m payer la faculté j'ai de le dire
mais à côté de ça côé mais voilà mais à
côté de ça moi je me suis responsabilisé
je j'ai pris l'autonomie et j'ai
travaillé le dimanche aussi pour payer
mes vacances pour payer m
sor vous arrêter parce que on arrive à
la fin de ce débat il est totalement
passionné mais je vois qu'à priori il y
a absolument pas possibilité de vous
mettre d'accord en tout cas tous les
trois enfin tous les
deux cl et Pascal sont d'accord pierreen
vous nêtes pas d'accord on comprend qu'
y a des logiques he qui s'opposent entre
une logique peut-être économique une
logique de liberté du travail et puis
une logique de philosophie même si un
peu réducteur mais je reste quand même
sur ma ma pensée quand même de
philosophie de de vie alors on on va
attendrec au service de l'homme et
l'homme ne doit pas être un outil au
service de l'économie merci à vous merci
beaucoup à vous d'avoir participé à ce
débat c'était c'était passionné on va
attendre du coup peut-être la
concertation de Jean-Claude pour voir
s'il va réussir à mettre tout le monde
d'accord ser ser
merci beaucoup à vous trois ce 78
société est terminé merci de votre
attention et à très bientôt
merci